he's here isn't he oh hey whoa hey hey
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the joy of creation
story mode now I didn't notice the
bloodstains on the door before they may
have been there or they may have just
added that in as I came into play the
Attic but let's go in there because this
is supposedly the last memory to recover
seems a little peculiar questions if I'm
going to die at least I want it oh why
can you at least give me that I'm sorry
it's just the way things have to go it's
just a part of life
their bodies are hardly keeping
themselves together so they're gathered
themselves in the basement they can't
just kill you directly you know I
promised them I leave you to them so I
brought you here to at least try to talk
to you everything burns I'd like to
thank you see the world through the eyes
of your creations being Michael Schmitt
has been an incredible experience I mean
I feel fantastic viewing to do that
okay I'm grumpy I'm ready to fight with
vistacal that rumbly in my tumbly
what are you doing space to switch sides
left to click to interact with items
looks like I'm gonna be going to classic
style of five nuts that for it is me a
computer and a whole bunch of
animatronics trying to rip my guts out I
don't know how to play this something
about X hi again okay what it x2 wait
did I just skip something hang on wait a
minute well that ain't good oh wait hang
on a second I've kind of forgotten about
what I was supposed to be doing there
what does this do what does that do huh
looking at there's a way to do something
FUS key I don't know what that's doing
alright ah that looks like a nightmare
vodka hunka hunka who knows how much
time has passed I came out Oh golden
freddy hides in the camera's flash him
twelve times two
what does that even mean I got a flash
him I keep giving the old dip show huh
that guy sends boy ed sounds bad sound
bad yeah you go back now okay so I got a
fling going Freddy
Ponca where you at boy I can't do
nothing about you what do I do I don't
know what to do about you there's no
instructions creation will break down
obstacles on its way to you flash him on
camera before he can proceed great but
that's not creation that is so I gotta
find oh oh that's a [ __ ] I got doors I
can slimmy slam down all right good to
know so I gotta find me a girl didn't
true do don't like the sound of that
Oh Freddy Fred boy I see you there I'm
gonna flash you soon system well that
don't look good
song hae get funked bralets get song yo
where you at
so I've only got so much dude adders
okay
okay right oh okay
and I gotta find girl Don from doe oh ah
that's that's bad throw that one down
okay that happens so I got to keep an
eye on these bad boys oh man there's a
lot to keep attractive Tobias the
Buster's welp I'm dead now golden freddy
got me doc that's a new one you're not
telling me to come back the enemies in
the Attic cameras only try to get inside
your room when the screen is black and
only one of them can enter at a time
Greg gray good got Deuter and doucher
over on the left on the right then we
got to keep the big boy creation boy on
the back end blast him back into a stone
oh hi see you hey that's one alright
good for me all right we're good
I just got a flashing twelve times huh
and that's all I got to do oh I see you
over there
oh I see you blink all right cool all
right we got going on that's low that
one down okay we got the guy on the left
I think maybe oh that's on fire
why is that on fire boy got you [ __ ] me
in the bite [ __ ] me quiet
oh we got someone on the right but I'm
not looking now we got someone on the
left but we got someone on the right
first I think let's see if we can get a
golden from I don't see him so I'm just
gonna boink ax okay there he is
I'm gonna get you from boy I have no
idea how many times I'm gonna lose track
very easily Chris friend be that bad let
me put that down be still on fire oh
that's not good wait hang on oh oh boy
okay we're fine fine okay see I know our
golden for a move
oh there he is
mmm
thunk whoa whoa oh he's a movin now see
golden boo boo you might as well get
whoa get back Oh
oh he had a chance I didn't get it okay
okay okay fine
oh that's not good he's coming quick
everything seems to be on some sort of
fire no good boy let's go on Fred boy
are you gonna stay there okay first
right then switch oh that's bad oh I'm
on fire the fire rises oh boy well it
seems like it might be death yep well I
can't find Fred man yeah
okay well I just such a shock to me
didn't go back oh where'd he go up he's
here isn't he oh hey whoa hey hey oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god if I look away do you just go away
that's my head in your mouth I am dead
okay so every I think the key is every
single time the switch comes off cool
down I have to use it either to shock
the guy or shock mister forbear what I
gotta do when he lit this on fire so I
guess that's bad oh well what can you do
about it
oh no oh no Rhonda
no no you were doing right well I was
correct but I didn't do it right I was
right there oh yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna
burn yeah I'm a bird okay I'm fine
[Applause]
[Music]
well I thought I won man found dead in
his own house body found by Landlord and
recently repaired country yeah what
who's dead
is that me dead cuz that looks like the
house from the beginning of the game I
don't like this I don't like this at all
Oh like none of this all right what does
it mean
just wait for 6:00 a.m. and it will all
feel it's night
go away baby please save please
[Music]
okay that's weird
some fishy going on here oh it's okay
fair it's okay we'll see
have you called 9-1-1 yeah
yes I did as soon as we got out I called
that like a few hours ago
[Music]
but I didn't don't worry buddies you're
safe
murders you're safe
you are safe
so all that
you are safe that's all you are see
that's all that see they're safe now
just as you wanted thank you for your
cooperation Scott Kauffman I'll take
care of everything from here well
alright then let's have that that's that
the way that that goes damn that is the
thing that that is that well so that's
it then huh okay anyway so body was
taken over by Michael and now Scott's
dead got the purple guy treatment to him
or something like that I have no idea
but either way this was amazing amazing
I'm not even lying about if this was
amazing this is by far the best five
nights at freddys fan game ever made and
I don't know I I kind of want to say I
enjoyed this even more than the actual
games themselves like just from a
gameplay standpoint
and I'm only speaking from a gameplay
standpoint because obviously this game
would not exist if those games didn't
exist before and obviously inspired this
I'm not saying one is better than the
other but just from like an enjoyable
atif actor like there's a lot of mystery
here there's a lot of story each level
had a unique mechanic an entirely unique
mechanic each of those levels could have
been their own self-contained games with
ramping difficulty but instead they were
all one and it was just awesome the
experience was great the developer this
guy
is just they may have been something
great they made something literally
great and it was free and I would have
paid money for this I would have paid 20
bucks for this I would have gladly paid
20 bucks for this oh man I don't know
how Scott feels about him being murdered
in a fan game but yeah it's whatever
it's probably more so I want to see
what's in the extra menu here because I
got a funky feeling it's probably
something funky fresh oh hi Fred boy I
was looking for you for so long oh
you're moving oh good for you
oh I can root op them oh goody goody gum
drop oh so we got Fred boy we got bunny
boy we got cheap the girl got foxy and
golden Freddy who's floating nice okay
yeah and they'll be angel Oh as in like
a weeping angel from Doctor Who because
that's kind of what it was not as fast
mind you but thankfully that's good endo
are blue endo sea mouth Oh
mouthy of is the one that surprised me a
few times and no F red mmm great
that's a foxy type creation I don't even
know why did you need to do this why was
this at all necessary this is the third
leg doing there in the stumpy arms you
ain't doing nothing boy so enemies
newspapers I didn't get all the
newspapers but yeah I did notice that I
was collecting newspapers throughout the
different places so there was living
room two nights of five nights at
Freddy's
let's see haunted woods cancelled new
fan asked am stopped and I got a
clipping only their tragedy continues to
haunt family in Texas as police failed
to find a missing man and the trail goes
cold so you get these pieces of these
newspapers throughout and I bet I bet
there's something there if you get if
you get all of these there's some secret
to be unlocked here and that means you
got to play it over again but there's
also bedroom blind mode baseman better
I'm blind I mean I could have probably
done it blind a guess I really need it
but I need to know where the
damn light is and then survival mode I
don't know what survival mode is but I
wanna see behind the scenes ah cool
oh the creation Oh cute oh man a lot of
work went into this that's the thing
like so much work went into this anyway
I want to see what I can get what these
are I want to see what survival mode is
they survive each level of the story
from beginning to end without stopping
you won't be able to pause the game no
cutscenes will be shown if you die once
you lose oh oh
then what's based from complete the
bedroom level without being able to see
your surroundings you won't be able to
pause the game no cutscenes will be
shown you can see for a limited amount
of time if you hold the F button if you
die once you lose what's the basement
run complete the basement level in under
8 minutes
it took me like 40 you won't be able to
pause game no cutscenes you will
automatically lose if you go over the
time limit you die you lose makes sense
to me okay so that's more challenges for
me to do so if you guys want to see
these let me know down in the comments
below but this game was amazing and
obviously there's a mystery to be solved
here in terms of the actual newspaper
clippings and I want to see where they
are I just don't know when it comes to
like the baby crib where would it have
been there underneath the pillar I don't
know but somewhere so either way thank
you everybody so much for watching just
stare at the lovely creation right here
and thanks again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]